today on Star Talk special edition I got
my co-host Chuck and Gary asking me
their most burning
questions and you will
learn why Chuck can lose a gasket over
thinking about time and you'll also find
out what Gary's deepest question is
about this universe and I have an answer
for it coming
[Music]
up this is Star Talk Neil degrass Tyson
here your personal astrophysicist uh I
got my co-host Chuck Nice Gary O'Reilly
how you guys doing hey Neil what's
happening hey all right th this is a
Star Talk special edition where every
now and
then it's just Chuck and Gary burning
questions whoa this was just for you
it's a gift back to you for being such
good co-hosts throughout the year every
now and then we got to throw back to you
because I know you have burning
questions I think you do not to be not
not to not to be confused with the kind
of burning questions that I ask my
doctor got o for that yeah
exactly okay I got some ointment to put
on your burning questions right yeah
there you go so got questions for me
what are you yeah I'm gonna start off
with something a little personal because
I always wanted to
know um after show a long time ago you
may or may not remember your colleague
from Princeton University who I believe
at the time was the head of the
Department of
astrophysics okay A friend of yours not
just a colleague because I I posted at
Princeton I I and spent another many
years there so I had very good friends
and colleagues there yes yes so
afterwards we were sitting around and
you guys got into this discussion about
the true size of the
universe and I tried to follow it but
then you went down a geek hole that was
so deep geek hole that I was just like
what the hell and I was fascinated by
just what and I didn't want of course I
was like just sitting there trying to
soak up as much of it as I could right
because that wasn't that never posted
that was just no that was just the two
of you
and I was like I and I did I I didn't
have my phone on set with me because I
wanted to pull out my phone and just
secretly record and be like this is how
they really talk when they're
alone this is what they really talk
about but anyway you guys were
disagreeing ever so slightly it's not
like you weren't saying the universe is
this size and he was saying no it's this
size you guys were dis agreeing very
slightly on the size and how you get to
the size okay and you started talking
about the only thing I understood was
red shifting but after that there was
some stuff man that you guys were
getting into so I just want to visit
that like you want a piece of that piece
that okay all right so a couple of
things all right if you ask any of us
what's the age of the universe we come
back at you with
13.8 billion years it's up slightly from
a couple of decades ago right uh with
better measurements if you asked me 20
years ago I would have said
13.7 billion years it's up slightly but
we have better data all right when I was
in graduate school we did not know the
age of the universe and nor the size of
the universe to within a factor of
two okay the universe was either 10
billion years old or 20 billion years
old two different camps depending on how
they valued the data that was being put
put forth it turns out the correct
answer was in between those two numbers
as you might expect okay as we narrow
down the uncertainty of the measurements
it turns
out there are two different measurements
of the age of the universe one of them
comes from supern noi that are exploding
at we what's good about supernovas when
they explode they're brighter than the
Galaxy they're contained in that's how
much energy they're putting out so you
can see Supernova basically to the edge
of the universe all right so they form a
good sort of what we call Standard
candle all right supernovas have
commonality among them you see where one
explodes how bright does it get how
quickly does it drop off in brightness
you calibrate that you can get a
distance to that Supernova okay and by
virtue of the expansion rate of the
universe you get an age of the universe
there's another method you get by
observing the cosmic microwave
background does not use Supernova each
of those are highly precise methods yet
they do not agree right with each other
on the size or the age of the universe
by a little bit and you can say oh it's
just a little bit no that the
uncertainties in each of these
measurements precludes the other answer
from being
correct okay D because we've narrowed
the uncertain so so the point it's
sounds you can have two numbers is it
13.75
13.83 well who cares between friends but
those two measurements are tight then
that's a problem it's a scientific
problem and it's called tension it's
it's called tension in the cosmological
mod you can Google tension cosmological
tension and it's unresolved at this
point last I checked we don't we can't
resolve the difference between these two
methods so either we don't understand
supern noi or we don't understand the
cosmic background but we think we do and
therefore we're getting the wrong
Precision in the answer or something
else is going on that might involve both
of them or maybe to think about the age
of the universe is a question that
doesn't have meaning unto itself it's
like saying what kind of cheese is the
moon made out
of right you could try to answer that
question no we know it's Swiss see we we
already know that we already know it's
Swiss
that's been solved that's scientifically
solved that was that stupid question
sorry I all right but if the universe is
constantly expanding Neil doesn't that
make
measurement
irrelevant all right so the measurement
would be in this moment right in the in
the current epic yes so now beyond that
because I'm trying to remember what that
conversation that you were Eaves
dropping on was that could have been
part of it but also we can say well how
big is the universe you might hear some
people say well it's
13.8 billion light years to the edge
okay I've said that that's a very common
thing you'll hear people
say more precisely and this is where we
get into the weeds that is how long it
has taken the light to reach us emitted
by objects on our
Horizon okay
right but over that time the universe
has
expanded so you can ask a different
question and say how far away is that
object
today you can't see it
today because this light hasn't reached
us today it only just released its light
today okay how far away is it today you
go back to your equations your models
and that object is like
46 billion light years away in that
direction and then the that Horizon goes
in the other direction too so the total
size of the observable universe today is
nearly a 100 billion light years
across right today but we don't see that
and so I'm raised in the you only talk
about what you can see camp and so we
see the galaxies on our Horizon and we
say they're 14.8 billion light years
away the light was emitted from the
Galaxy when it was 14.8 billion uh 13.8
billion um light years away so that's
what we were hashing out when the
cameras weren't rolling that you rudely
Eaves dropped on yeah well I'm glad I
did and I'll do it
again okay so why why we discussing the
size of the universe now will the
universe continually expand or will it
get to a point to go had enough okay
yeah yeah so wait let me finish
something up with Chuck you can say well
I gave you the size of the observable
universe but how about the actual
Universe right we don't
know I don't know how far beyond our
Horizon the actual Universe goes anymore
than if I plunk you down in the Nina the
Pinta and the Santa Maria in the middle
of the Atlantic just plunk you down
there you would not know how far the
ocean goes beyond your horizon right
you'd have to like sail it and continue
to sail it until one day you run out of
ocean right so yeah but that Horizon
although it appears to be moving is
actually not whereas the universe's
Horizon is actually moving oh so so our
Horizon yes it is moving outward right
at the speed of light okay that has
nothing to do with the expansion speed
it's the speed of light with which our
Horizon is growing so in a billion years
our Horizon will not be 13.8 let's round
it to 14 our Horizon will be 15 billion
light years away okay the light Horizon
and in another billion it be 16 billion
and every next billion years it is our
Horizon is washing
over whole other parts of the universe
that previously never reached us whose
light had previously never reached us so
here's the freaky part you get to 15
billion years what do you see you're
seeing the big
bang for those galaxies because their
big bang light is only only now just
reaching us so the Big Bang signature is
a continual signature that's expanding
at the speed of light because every next
gener every next layer of galaxies
you're watching them being born and then
the next one being born and then the
next one and then the next
one and that's because the speed of
light is not infinite if the speed of
light were infinite you'd have no
knowledge of the
past and you know who one of the first
people to try to measure the speed of
light take a
guess um I'm gonna say well maybe people
tried earlier but but it's Galileo oh
who Galileo G he put two people on
mountain tops with lanterns okay and say
and and when one flashed the other would
open the the shutter on one and close on
the other and I love his the results of
his experiment um I bet you the results
were George is too
slow I don't know what the hell is wrong
with George I give him the queue yes
somehow he is missing this damn q no
wait this is Italy so what's George in
Italy oh oh uh Giani no that's Giani
giovan is too slow GI
Johnny yeah Giovanni is Johnny but
whatever
that's why George is that's why George
is getting it wrong cuz he keep calling
him
Johnny that's a dude on the other
mountain right okaya so so I I gotta
remember uh he said something like um if
it's not infinitely
fast if it's not infinite it is
remarkably fast because he could not
measure the speed couldn't measure the
speed but he was he was he's a scientist
so he he doesn't have a number it's just
faster that he could measure so he
allowed it to be like infinite but or
really fast faster than Giovani could
open the shutters of his Lantern on the
opposite Mountain so point is if the if
light were infinitely fast we'd see the
entire universe all at once all the time
and all at once so the Big Bang is not
some moment in time that happens to be
captured by these galaxies and the
cosmic microwave background in this
moment that will always be there and
it's not cuz it's the same thing that's
there there's other galaxies being born
that are get now giving you their
information and at 15 billion years the
the cosmic microwave background that we
now see all of that became galaxies
stars and
galaxies so it's a
fascinating a time machine that the
expanding Universe the extent of the
universe and the speed of light hands us
which is why we have cosmology at all
damn now to to so Gary the expansion of
the universe all data points to that's a
one-way trip when I was in graduate
school we were always considering might
we one day we collapse if you want to
recollapse you need enough mass and
gravity to sort of pull it back again
the gra the universe is expanding at the
escape velocity of the universe itself
so it will not come back ever so get
over it
no no no no just the thought you know
hey it's our burning questions and
needed to put this fire
out G gab you had you had a burning
another burning question oh God one of
many um I'm sure the same um give me one
all right let's I'll see if I have I'll
see if I have ointment for your burning
questions here well that is so kind and
considerate of you yes yes but you going
apply you're you're going to apply the O
the ointment your own damn self yeah I
get it which
friends that's the difference between
being a doctor of astrophysics and a
medical
doctor you got your Dam your
astrophysics is like here's the ointment
now go on about your damn
business so if I if I think about us as
a species and our intentions to go into
deep space okay that's most likely going
to happen at some point in the future
I'm not going to put a number next to it
but at some point in the future but how
are we going to communicate in deep
space I mean how how do we get through
to the point where we got reliable
realtime communication between ourselves
I mean is it even possible viable it's
not it's not Star Trek where they have
if we had if we had my what's it called
Subspace Subspace Communications yeah
there's something called Subspace where
they can communicate basically instantly
and we have no way to do that so what
would say is because so for example uh
by the way this shows up with our Rovers
on Mars those Rovers have to be at least
semi autonomous because we can't say
look out for the cliff and then 20
minutes later the signal gets there
depending on where Earth and Mars are
relative to each other in our orbits
that's how long it can take the signal
to get there and then it drives off the
cliff and you lost your Rover Rover has
to know what to not do without you
giving an in instructions to tell her to
not do it so um and by the way if it did
go off the cliff you wouldn't know it
for another 20 minutes because then
that's when the signal comes back to you
so it's a 40 minute round trip when the
astronauts were on the Moon the Moon has
a like a two to three second roundtrip
DeLay So the phone call between the most
build is the most expensive phone call
ever conducted between the president of
the United States and the Apollo 11 crew
on the
moon that had delays so I you know so
you can't have witty reparte right uh
when you're talking to people in deep
space not even on the moon you can't say
hey Chuck how you doing and then I gotta
wait one and a half seconds for it to
get to you and then one the
answer
okay and then I get that oh three
seconds later okay he's okay okay so
that's this doesn't work and by the way
so bad that is here's something people
forgot about so bad that is that the
delay to our communication satellites is
too
long to be acceptable in a phone
call okay before we had GPS and before
we had cell phone towers there were
communication satellites we still have
them but they're not used for talking to
each other that park it between Europe
and the United States because they're
geosynchronous geostationary so they're
high so high up their orbit exactly
matches the rotation rate of the Earth
all right 23 hours 56 minutes turning
all right that's the rotation rate of
the earth once and four seconds all
right so it does that so now you beam
something from the United States up to
that satellite which is
23,000 miles up then it goes back down
to Europe which it can do because it
sees both continents because it's
sitting right between us over the
Atlantic Ocean and then it beams back up
and back so that full round trip it's
23,000 miles up 23,000 miles down 23,000
miles back up 23,000 miles back down
that's basically 100,000 miles the speed
of light is 186,000 miles per second so
that full round trip is basically a half
a
second now when you have a conversation
where everything you say is delayed a
half a second before the person replies
you can't for example interrupt them
it's it's like the old days when people
spoke on CBS you just give information
you say over and out and wait for them
to get it and then they'd speak back
okay that's called Simplex communication
where you can only take signals in One
Direction at a time then you can have
duplex or Multiplex but point is even
that was too slow which led to so Elon
Musk has satellites that are in lower
Earth orbit lower Earth orbit so that
the time travel up and back is just fine
for you to talk on a cell phone and so
so these are issu so that's a long
conversation to say um Gary that these
delays are important and they're a
problem you would hope that if you're
far enough away you don't need to talk
to Houston you got all the solutions you
need okay or you don't have to speak to
them with ready witty parte there'd be
really hard for standup ComEd comedy you
wouldn't know people were
laughing still used to
it is this mic on I know you're out I
know you're out there I can hear you
breathing but is is there another means
of
communicating wait wait wait so so if if
we don't travel through space until we
invent wormholes with this mythical
substance that has negative
gravitational energy
negative gravitational force to pry open
the fabric of space in time if we move
through space through wormholes then so
could
communication right so if you go if
you're on your way to Alpha centuri on
our faster spaceships today it would
take you 70,000 years and you could be
in a generational spaceship and make
babies that they grow up and then they
make babies and they grow up and you all
die and then you know uh 30 30 th no uh
what would it be 2,000 Generations now
then that Civilization on the ship
arrives
okay um that's a long time in the future
yeah and all I'm saying is between now
and then we might invent
wormholes at which point we just step
past you and wave and say we'll see you
in 35,000 years as we get to alphason
Cherry system so if we have worm holes
communication goes through it and the
communication is instant yes h Chuck
burning question what else you got okay
so this is a
very I'm I'm just going to read the
question but then you got to break down
everything that's a part of it in order
for everybody to know what I'm talking
about well this is your day and Gary's
day so I will I'm at your service okay
cool okay all right how can a single
electron passing through by prisms or
slits interfere with
itself nobody knows oh man come on next
[Laughter]
question yeah no this is these are the
these are the mysteries of quantum
physics like I said and Gary finish my
sentence the universe is under no
obligation to make sense or care about
your
gender all right so in that case then
the point is particles can behave as
waves and do behave as okay so I get the
duality of light in that it's a wave and
a particle yes okay but so first of all
maybe we should tell people what the
double slit experiment is okay so here's
the thing you're looking at electrons
coming through through you have this
barrier right and you put two slits
adjacent to one another you know six
inches doesn't matter to separate them
they two SL then you have a screen on
the other side and you fire electrons
into this and you know you know where
the electrons are you fire them in and
you'll get two points of intensity on
the back screen one in front of one slit
one in front of the other slit and
there's be some fade off to the left and
right of that because some will get bent
a little okay that's what happens if
they are
electrons now you don't look at it and
you do the same
experiment on the back wall you don't
see two two uh Peaks you you see what we
what's called an interference pattern
right of the variation of light and dark
Peaks that completely spreads across the
projection surface because when you
didn't look at it the electron behaved
as a wave and when you did look at it it
behaved as
electron and so when a wave waves can
interfere so a wave is a just what you
think it is it's ups and downs if you
have two waves that are intersecting
with each other there'll be points where
the crests match up you get an extra
high peak points where the troughs match
up get an extra low Peak and these just
continue and you get all combinations of
the two and what that looks like and
what we call it in physics is an
interference pattern and that's evidence
that for that variant of the experiment
the electrons would behaving as waves
now what does what is looking at it have
to do with it because if you're looking
at it you got to shine light on it right
if you shine light on it because
otherwise it's just it's an experiment
in the dark you have no idea what's
happening at all the moment you shine
light on it the light interferes with
the electrons being waves and they
become particles at that
point and so it's called the observer
effect and the new age circles want to
believe that it's your Consciousness
that's affecting it and that's one of
the biggest misconceptions that Contin
that's ridiculous who was it first
discovered this with waves back in the
day way
back uh well we knew we knew about the
wave
interference okay because you were
always Shining Light on your electrons
but electrons had to be discovered right
the electrons were not known in
Antiquity they had to be discovered and
then you got to know how to manipulate
them and then you do these experiments
this is all we are in the Centennial
decade of the birth of quantum physics
the 1920s was a seminal
set of years where quantum physics was
discovered Hubble discovered that we're
not the only galaxy in the universe and
he discovered that the Universe was
expanding so a lot went on in that
decade so Chuck we we don't know it just
is it just is it is a correct
description of Nature and an important
philosophical point just because we
don't know how something works right not
why something works doesn't mean we
can't describe how works
right okay so you can know you can know
things and predict things even if you
don't fully understand what's happening
and that's where we are with quantum
physics we don't it defies our common
sense but so does practically everything
else about quantum physics we we don't
live in the quantum right there's a book
called oh what's the guy's name oh
George gamma physicist wrote a book
called Mr Tomkins in Wonderland and it's
a series and one of the stories is the
physical constants are different in his
world so as he's driving down the street
he starts seeing relativistic things
happen and all Einstein's relativity
shows up in his rear view mirror in his
front view mirror very clever um uh
educational tooling there so one of them
it's quantum physics so Plank's constant
which measures the things in the quantum
Is some much larger value which means
when you walk through a a
doorway you end up defc just the way
particles would I mean there's it's
freaky stuff it's called Mr Tomkins in
Wonderland it's a whole series very
clever and he Illustrated it has fun
little cartoons in it too I learned
everything I know about the quantum from
Ant-Man Quantum Mania
oh
okay the Marvel Universe yeah which is
why I know nothing about the quantum
because it
was
all right okay here's one Neil this is
something that we have talked about in
the past several times
and the fact that it is real is just
very difficult to wrap my head around
okay okay and that is we have kinematic
time dilation we have gravitational time
dilation and these are not perceptions
because you told me about the atomic
clock
experiment and so the atomic
clocks are the most precise
chronological measurement of time and we
end up with different readings in these
experiments I'm is time real is it a is
it a thing is it is it even a thing is
it even a thing for real I mean come on
Chuck is blowing a gasket I'm serious
just blew a gasket okay are humans are
humans the only species that kind of
measure time or no no do so for example
you've heard of halflife right yes of
course halflife okay and halflife limit
let's make sure we're on the same page
there are certain elements that are
radioactive which means they Decay into
different elements you start with a with
a blob of one element and if it has a
halflife of a week let's say that means
in a week
on average half of those atoms will have
turned into a different kind of atom
right they would have decayed and then
in another week half of what remains
turns into it okay it's half of a half
of a half of a half of a half of a half
and it drops rapidly it's two to the N
power right so it drops rapidly okay so
if you have 10 half lives then you have
one
1,000th of what was there before left
over because 10 is two it's 1 halftimes
1 halftimes 1 halftimes 1 half times 1
half and you get
1,24 I think right so it's basically
1,000th of what was there all right you
can take an
element that has a
halflife and accelerate it to near the
speed of
light and its Decay will be
delayed by the exact amount that you
calculated in Einstein's
relativity and it's not carrying a timx
with it okay or
Rolex it's an whatever internal clock
tells Adams to
Decay that is adjust that is affected by
relativity so time is real relativity is
real now one way to think of it where
which Jan 11 has tried mightily to get
us to understand
all right if you have uh two
axes okay and one axis is distance and
the other is time
okay or not distance it's just space one
is space the other is time and they're
like right angles to each other all
right so it's two
axes
now if you're sitting there going
nowhere you are not moving on the space
axis but you are moving in the time axis
aren't you yes time is going forward for
you right because your lazy ass is on
the couch and you're not actually moving
anywhere okay okay so if you start
moving then the line on this graph that
applies to
you is not the one that's going straight
up the time axis because now you are
moving from your previous location and
now you're in a new location and you're
continuing to move so now as time
progressives you you advance a little
bit in the space
Direction so you have a line that's at
an angle right now right from the
vertical can we picture this in our
heads of course yeah okay you got it
okay okay great great so now so now I I
so you Chuck you you've been slow lately
Gary's a former ex pro pro footballer
he's gonna run while he watch you walk
eating potato chips okay he will run you
are both both moving forward in time yes
but he's moving farther in distance than
you right in the same amount of time so
his line will be at an even greater
angle than yours will okay right we got
this so far yeah okay now everybody's
got to measure the speed of light to be
the
same this is one of the great insights
that Albert Einstein had in his
relativity okay in order for both of you
to measure the speed of light to be the
same
thing your time coordinates have to
change have to change his would have to
slow down in order if if speed of light
is a constant his time which is that
because the speed of light's got to
remain the same correct correct so that
means his time would literally have to
slow down in order for him to observe me
eating time at the same time Jesus
Christ see this is what I'm talking
about what what what what what we're
both seeing the time the time slows for
him but it's the same for me because the
speed of light is time is
man Chu
it literally slows down for him
literally it is not like it's a
perception
the
everything his metabolism his thoughts
his any radioactive material he's
carrying in his pocket his clock
everything the vibrations of the atoms
everything and referentially for me
everything is exactly the same for me my
time is staying the same for me okay but
for him to observe me his time actually
has to slow down in order for that
observation to no no so let me to be
more clear you're watching him I'm sorry
I'm watching him that's what I I didn't
mean that I said it backwards and so
when you okay start so you're watching
him and from where you are you both want
to measure the speed of light to be the
same but the only way that can happen is
if you see him move slower right he's
got to move slower because his time and
it's not like it's not like I'm
perceiving him to move slower his time
literally has to
slow so that he can make the same
measurement make the same measurement
that I correct okay now now now if you
go at the speed of light time stops so
that would be what's so that's so that
would be a line moving along the
distance axis yeah but not advancing
along the time time axis it would just
be Flatline there and so therefore a
beam of light can get between any two
places with zero elapsed time so a a a
light a a photon particle of light
emitted in the center of the Galaxy
which was the object of my affection for
my PhD thesis the galactic center those
photons I will see them travel for
30,000 years but if you're that Photon
you don't you don't live for any time at
all no time that's right there's no time
you detected in the same instant you are
emitted right
correct okay so we gotta get talk truck
off the ledge there it's crazy this is
and seriously it's it's it's so funny
because it's it's all it's okay forget
it it is mindblowing that you know that
these are for the measurements
themselves these are true measurements
you would think that these would be
perceptions because you're talking about
it being relative to an observer but
they're not perceptions yeah in fact
Observer is is an unfortunate word that
we still use today we still use we refer
to Observer and a phenomenon and people
then think it's something something to
do with you for being human exactly and
it really isn't these are actual
measurements and the measurements
themselves are true and
correct as they relate to the time and
the constant being the speed of light
that's insane man yeah crazy it's just
crazy it's crazy yeah and and another
example we've G given it before but now
you we have our own private burning
question session here that um this
phenomena occurs in the strength of a
gravitational field as well so the
stronger is the gravitation field the
slower your time so our GPS satellites
so GPS satellites fly in moo right we
have Leo moo and and Geo right so moo
Middle Earth orbit and so those are like
12,000 miles up and so that's high okay
that's farther away than the diameter of
the earth is above the Earth so they are
far enough away from Earth Center that
the difference in timekeeping for them
is different than it is for us right
okay so their T their clocks since
they're farther away from are moving
faster relative to us right so when they
keep track of time and send us the time
we have to correct it because we care
about the time in our reference frame
which is Earth's surface so who
calibrates this what calculation are
they we got people that's why there's a
National Bureau of Standards I mean
there there're people who think way you
got to be glad they're there and they're
the unsung heroes you don't even know
they're there and they're figuring this
out for you so and let me tell you how
how deep it goes they all use the timx
okay so what let me how deep it goes so
um we're on Earth's surface and we think
of it as just one surface but there's
something called the
geode and the geode is the grid that the
GPS satellite is actually talking
to now in that grid is the geode you're
using for earth a perfect
sphere okay that's a model of Earth's
surface but that's not Earth's surface
Earth's Earth is wider slightly wider at
the equator than it is at the poles the
equator is farther away from Earth
Center than people not on the equator
which affects which time frame you are
in relative to the GPS
satellites so if you want to be really
really really really precise you have to
know where you are on the
geode relative between the perfectly
spherically modeled Earth and the Earth
that has that's slightly wider at the
equator than at the poles and by the way
we're not only an oblate spheroid
slightly wider at the equators than at
the poles we are slightly wider below
the equator than at the
Equator so we're a pearshaped
oblate
spheroid and that's harder to model
mathematically so TP and usually you
don't care about that level of precision
so so typically they just use a
spherical approximation for Earth's
surface and let the dust fall where it
may are we talking Nan seconds here or
we're talking about you're one doorway
away from where you were had intended to
be that sort of thing but you're usually
tracking down an address and so once you
see the address you're not still using
GPS to decide that you know who needs
these coordinates the military because
if they're sending a missile via GPS
guidance yeah door make a difference yes
the doorway to the left or the right
makes a difference right so yeah they
have to know what the exact shape of the
earth is at the point where they're um
interacting and of course GPS was
invented by the military by the US Air
Force now under the control of the US
Postal Service
no they don't want to get the wrong
mabox he's a Brit we'll excuse him on
this one Chuck the GPS was designed and
built by the military and it it's it is
it is controlled by it was controlled by
the US Air Force
until it is now under the control
of the
US space for
oh I you know why I have never accepted
space
force that's why I was wondering I was
like why am I not getting this and I
cannot begin to tell you how irrelevant
that fact is I know to the world I know
and I need to that you don't accept it
and I need to get over it because guess
what and you and and I just felt first
of all I thought it was a dumbass name
and what what it's space and it's a for
wait wait dude dude come down CU listen
we already shud we already have the Air
Force and then you just going to oh and
now look at to make it space force okay
hold on hold on okay so we still have
the Air
Force they worry about the air okay
space force worries about stuff that is
not moving through the air okay those
are called satellites and other Rockets
all right did you complain in 1947 when
the Air Force split from the US Army
well no no because you weren't born but
had you been around would you be would
you be imitating who was president 1947
uh who was it uh a Truman would you be
imitating Truman and say and saying well
why have an an Air Force when we have
the Army who can fully take care of the
Air Force the Army has soldiers on the
ground with tanks sounds cool it sounds
cool Truman had it right it sounds cool
you know where space force sounds like
something that um science fictiony that
Seth no that Seth uh McFarland came up
with that's what space force sounds like
sounds like Seth they were like Seth we
need a we need a name we need a name for
an organization that's gonna uh put us
out in space and take care of all our
space
related how about space force let's go
with space force like no no so the
entire space branch of the Air Force
basically pulled away to become the
space force where command and control is
different all the the uh there's so much
that it's it's maybe not entirely as
different from the Air Force as Air
Force was from the Army right but it's
different enough to justify its own
branch and now they have a seat at the
table in the Joint Chiefs of Staff y
Gary we got time for only one more
burning question but it has to be can't
just be any question it has to be
burning okay
what is the one scientific breakthrough
for you that has shaped the world the
most and maybe what is the next one for
you that has shaped the current world
yeah the
fact
that
matter is made of
atoms and atoms are made of
particles
really I don't think anything has
shaped the world more than that
knowledge and awareness that's a that's
a really cool answer because that's what
gives us electricity yep y it gives us
the nuclear power all of our
Communications it gives us our
understanding of molecules yeah how and
why they work it gives us our
understanding of the periodic table of
elements why is it periodic
okay all of that comes from that
fundamental
realization because think of it before
then it's like Oh I'm a wood cutter I
just care that my wood atoms you say
it's Adams okay I got wood atoms fine I
don't care I'm just GNA cut okay oh but
wait a minute when you burn wood what
happens oh there molecules there that
have energy that break apart okay so
there it is that's a that's a really
answer I would have never thought of it
that way but yeah yeah that that
Discovery changes everything and and if
I can tell you one other thing there's
some professors at MIT who created a
course called Energy and big fat
textbook everything you ever wanted to
know about
energy machines the conversion of energy
from one thing to another this goes on
and on and on get more of it in the
afternoon because I got a so bad around
2 you know I don't know if they get the
caffeine
energy wa so let me get the book hold on
a sec here's the
book the physics of
energy okay Robert jaffy and Washington
Taylor okay two professors and look how
fat the book is right and so I want to
read to you
my um I I wrote a blur for it okay a
blur
technical term yeah it's a total
technical term here it is you
ready and I pride myself on always
having the shortest
blurb uh but this one is about the same
length as the others okay so here it
goes
ready if your task was to jumpstart
civilization but had access to only one
book then the physics of energy would be
your choice professors Taylor and jaffy
have written a comprehensive thorough
and relevant treaties it's an energizing
read as a standalone book but it should
also be a course offered at every
College lest we mismanage our Collective
role as Shepherds of our energy hungry
energy dependent
civilization wow and then they inscribed
it to me a little inscription there I'll
read that to you uh dear Neil here's
hoping we don't have to jump start
civilization anytime soon how about that
oh that's very funny so I would say a
close second to knowledge that there are
particles is the fact that we have
learned to understand measure harness
and
transform energy from one form to
another that in fact is the backbone of
modern
civilization true good answ my question
got a great answer thank you oh man or
was it just a great question and I gave
an average
answer no take credit Gary take take it
away you can get it I'm taking it
running I'm running all right well I
enjoyed this get my my co-host giving
them a chance to ask burning questions
we might make this a regular thing I
don't know but you have to earn it we
got to get through like many other
episodes before we can't make it too
regular there's people who pay us money
to ask questions ask to ask their
questions right ask their questions
we're gon we're gonna get into the
lobbying business
[Laughter]
all right Gary all right chck this this
has been Star Talk Neil degrass Tyson
here with burning questions from Chuck
and Gary as always I bid you to keep
looking
[Music]
up